seen a number of variants over the last
three years now starting with the the
first one the alpha variant and then all
the way to Omicron and is
um children and grandchildren if you
like it's what we're gonna see in the
next Generations so the key is to
papanas is constant vigilance and
monitoring and for that we are better
equipped than before we have
um surveillance systems in place
Wastewater surveillance from which we
can derive analysis about variants and
their proportions as well as the
genomics platform where we analyze the
genome on these viruses and and that's
not just in Canada but globally there's
increased capacity monitor changes in
the virus so that that is good and then
in terms of the reactions
um you know studying the outcomes of
these variants is very important just
because you detected the genetic change
we the doesn't mean that it causes any
different clinical manifestations so
that's another thing we have to learn is
rapidly determine if its course is more
severe illness and we've demonstrated
that globally and within Canada we can
we've done better in terms of trying to
link that but I think we still need some
improvements on linking laboratory and
clinical data people are just fed up
with you know covid-19 full stop and yet
the virus hasn't left us and we've had
to keep updating our vaccine
recommendations as well as updating the
vaccines themselves and so that's
understandable but I think we need to
provide information and in a as
accessible way as possible to people to
explain why vaccines are needed but also
I think engage trusted voices Community
leaders people that different
communities trust in order to uh
increase uptake this isn't our only
winter and only respiratory viruses and
with these viruses it would be expected
to get influenza and RSV but the problem
is we're getting them all at once after
two to three years of not having these
viruses circulating so it is slightly
special but we're going to be going
through this again and again in the
years to come we've just had these new
tools people need to develop these
personal habits and there's a is I think
on the ground with the other chief
medical officers is you've got to get
the balance of not actually doing the
opposite which is when the public is so
fed up that they're offsides with your
messaging
um so I I still think that that's
another pandemic Lessons Learned is that
when it comes to important time periods
collectively we can make a difference we
can write our own story as to what
happens post holiday season if we took
these measures we will come out of this
next weeks the next couple of weeks
um and and more safely